التسرب المدرسي شبح يخطف الاطفال من مقاعد
المدرسه ويقول لهم الى السوق العمل مبكرا
جدا ظاهره تتوحش بمرور الوقت وتعاني منها
عدد من الدول العربيه ومصر من اكبر
المتضررين الحكومه المصريه يبدو انها قررت
ان ترفع رايه الحرب عبر تشريع جديد يعاقب
اولياء الامور الذين يقررون سحب ابنائهم
من المدرسه وعدم استكمال تعليمهم مشروع
القانون الجديد الصحه عنه رضا حجازي وزير
التربيه والتعليم المصري امام البرلمان
لكنه لم يحدد ماهيه العقوبات المفروضه على
الاسر مع وجود الميحات لربط الدعم
الحكوميه للاسر بماده التزام ابنائهم في
الدراسه الخطه تقضي باحتواء معدلات الاميه
المرتفعه ومحاصره الجهل عند ارباب الاسر
في المستقبل بخلاف الحد من زواج القاصرات
المزيد مع نجاح
[موسيقى]
نحن على مشارفي
وثقافه العيل بيجي برزقه لا تزال شائعه
بين مواطن الفئات البسيطه في مصر ومحرك
اساسيا في ارتفاع معدلات الانجاب واستمرار
زياده السكانيه لكن كيف جاء مفهوم العيل
بيجي برزقه المشكله مركبه وتجر معها
الكثير من المشكلات واساسها التسرب من
التعليم
اولياء الامور في كثير من المناطق يجبرون
ابنائهم على ترك المدرسه
لمساعدتهم على جني لقمه العيش واستغلالهم
لجلب عوائد ماديه في ظل غلاء المعيشه
الحكومه المصريه تخطط لفرد عقوبه صارمه
على اولياء الامور بالاسرى التي تتعمد
تسريب اولادها من التعليم
ومواجهه العماله تحت السن والاهم تقليل
معادلات الاميه حسبما اعلن رضا حجازي وزير
التربيه والتعليم في كلمته الاخيره امام
البرلمان
[موسيقى]
الجهل هو راس الفتن ومصائبه لا تاتي فرادى
التصدي له بحسم يعني القضاء بالتابعيه على
ظواهر تارق المجتمع وتعرقل اي خطط للتنميه
لصباح العربيه ندى حجازي القاهره
نجحت مصر في خفض معدلات التسرب من التعليم
على مدار الخمس سنوات الماضيه واليكم
الارقام 87 من مائه في المئه هي نسبه
التسرب بالمرحله الاعداديه عام 2021
مقارنه ب 3.8 عام 2018
صفر فاصل 20% هي نسبه التصرف في المرحله
الابتدائيه عام 2021 مقارنه بصفر فاصل 38
عام 2018
25,00080 طالبا وطالبا متسربون من التعليم
في المرحله الابتدائيه عام 2021 ومدينه
الاسكندريه تتصدر الترتيب
43,351 طالب وطالبه متسربون من المرحله
الاعداديه عام 2021
حفضت البحيره تتصدر ترتيب ايضا
53.71% هو معدل انتقال الطلاب من المرحله
الاعداديه الى المرحله الثانويه بالقاهره
وهي النسبه الاعلى بين نقيه المحافظات
[موسيقى]
على كل من الخير ينضم لنا المحامي المختص
بقضايا حقوق الاطفال احمد مصلح الذي
سنناقش معه فورا توفره مشروع القانون
المصري الجديد الذي يقضي اذن في معاقبه
الاهالي الذين يتسببون بظاهره التسرب
المدرسي لابنائه وهي قويه يعاني منها او
تعاني منها العديد من الدول العربيه ولكن
بحسب اخر الاحصاءات مصر هي اكبر المتضررين
بهذه الظاهره من القاهره
المختص بقضايا حقوق الاطفال احمد مصلحي
سيد احمد اهلا بك معنا صباح العربيه مشروع
قانون مصر الجديد لمعاقبه الاولياء الذين
يتسبون بالتسرب المدرسي لابنائهم حدثنا
اكثر عن همم هذا المشروع الجديد
في البدايه احنا لازم ناكد ان القانون
الطفل المصري بيحمي الطفل باكبر قدر ممكن
هذه الحمايه طبعا تشمل حمايته من التسرب
للتعليم لان يلي ده تماما وجود الطفل في
حاله من حالات التعرض للخطر من الممكن ان
يوجد في سوق العمل مهما كان العمل ده سواء
اذا كان عمل في الشارع في حاله من حالات
التسول مثلا او عمل في اي سوق من سوق
العمل عمل حتى في الريف المصري ده شكل من
اشكال
الخطوره الكبيره اللي اللي بتبدا من
التصرف من التعليم وتنتهي ممكن همم ان
تودي حياه الطفل نفسه همم ممكن ان يوجد
الطفل في حاله في في حاله عمل توني بحياته
او اكثر من الناحيه القانونيه لو سمحت همم
الحكومه المصريه لم تخفي فرض عقوبات صارمه
ومشدده على الاهالي الذين تسببون بتسرب
اولادهم للمدرسه ويجبرون اولادهم على ترك
همم مقاعد الدراسه من الناحيه القانونيه
ما هي هذه العقوبات ما طبيعتها
الوضع الحالي مجرد تسرم التعليم هو حاله
من حالات التعرض للخطر ااه
العقاب المباشر همم على هذه الحلقه فقط في
القانون القديم لم يكن هناك همم عقاب همم
بالحبسه او الغرامه همم المشروع الجديد هو
همم اذا تسرب الطفل وكان السبب هي الاسره
همم
تفرض عقوبه على المتسبب في هذا التصرف همم
ست شهور همم حبس او الغرامه وهنا القاضي
يحدد همم مدى همم المتسبب والظروف
والملابسات وبناء عليه بيصدر الحكم همم من
الممكن ان تشدد العقوبه لان القانون بياكد
على اذا كان المتسبب هو اللقائم على تربيه
الطفل سواء اذا كان مثلا الاسره او وجد
مثلا في دار من دور الرعايه والقائم عليها
وهو كان السبب في همم التسربه من التعليم
تشدد العقوبه تصل الى سنه حبس او الغرامه
طبعا وهنا ده بياكد على مدى حمايه الطفل
بشكل كبير من الت- طبعا الخطوره اللي ممكن
تنتج على انتصارهم من التعليم ده غير ان
التسرب من تعليمه هيحرمه من التعليم وده
في حد ذاته جريمه وفق القناه المصري وفق
التعدين
ذلك الى همم مساعده الابناء مساعدتهم في
جنين لقمه العيش في هذه الحاله ان نتوقع
من الناحيه القانونيه ان تقوم الحكومه
بدعم الاهالي مقابل التزامهم باخذ اولادهم
المدرسه
ايوه
بالضبط يا فندم بالضبط في احنا القانون
بيفرض دعم
لكل طفل لكل طفل مجرد الميلاد اذا حرم من
مصدر الرزق او كان الاب في حاله اقتصاديه
ضعيفه هنا
في دعم لكل طفل ااا غير ان التعليم بيتوفر
له التعليم مجاني تماما ما بيدفعش مبالغ
بيبقى ليه اا صندوق توفير وزاره التضامن
الاجتماعي بالتحديد هي اللي بتتولى فكره
الحمايه الاجتماعيه والماليه لهذا الطفل
اذا تاكدت الوزاره عن طريق تقرير مفصل
بيوضح هذا التقرير ان اا الاسره غير قادره
على همم
غير قادره ماليه على همم توفير كل
احتياجات الطفل في هذه الحاله وبالتالي ما
فيش اي همم
يعني بنقولها بشكل مباشر مبرر للاسره ان
ان يحرم هذا الطفل بالتعليم لان هو حق
اصيل وحق اساسي سواء اذا كان في اتفاقيه
حقوق الطفل او كان في قانون الطفل المصري
12 سنه 96 شكرا جزيلا لك حدثنا من القاهره
المحامي المختص بقضايا حقوق الاطفال احمد